so that was the video uh if you liked it
you can like And subscribe that anyways
bye hit like And subscribe for a cookie
like And subscribe or I will murder your
family no I'm just kidding you know I
love you guys don't forget to smash that
like button only a small percent of my
viewers are actually subscribed to my
channel so I'd appreciate it if you
subscribed also it's free you can change
your mind anytime you want hey guys I
don't usually do this even though I say
this every video but if you could like
or subscribe to my channel I'd really
appreciate it I would never mention
likes and subscribers except in a
mocking way you know like hit like And
subscribe this makes you think I'm not
like other YouTubers even though this
attempted subversion is really just
another ploy to get you to like And
subscribe this message is being
transmitted through brain waves forcing
you to like And subscribe against your
will anyways I spent 100 days at
Minecraft and [ __ ] got crazy